يعني نحن الان نتواجد في القرب الكنيست
حيث يتوافد عشرات الالاف من الاسرائيليين
مناطق مختلفه سواء من تل ابيب كان هناك
ايضا حضور كبير من تل ابيب من القطارات
كان هناك يعني توجه اعداد كبيره من
الاسرائيليين الى القطارات والى
المواصلات وتوجهوا من مناطق مختلفه الى
الى القتل يحتج ضد هذه التعديلات القضائيه
للمره الاولى يعني نشهد ليله امس كان هناك
اشتباكات بين اسرائيليين من اليمين
واسرائيليين من اليسار حيث يتظاهروا اما
اليوم هناك يعني من المتوقع ان تشهد
اسرائيل مظاهره كبيره وكبيره جدا ربما
الاكبر ستكون في القدس منذ بدء المظاهرات
منذ اكثر من 12
اسبوعا لكن اليوم ايضا نتحدث عن انتظار
الاسرائيليين كلمه نتنياه حيث من المتوقع
ان يخرج ويتحدث الشعب يعني من المتوقع
ايضا ان يقوم ربما تاجيل هذه التعديلات
القضائيه او حتى يعني ايقافها بشكل مؤقت
ولكن ايضا هناك دعوات من قبل
بنكيرتش بدعوات من قبلهم لخروج اليمينيين
ايضا الى التظاهر في الشوارع في القدس ضد
ايضا
المتظاهرين الموجودين اليوم في القدس هل
اي لا نتلمحتم او كنا نتحدث ونسمع في بس
عندي سؤال فيما يتعلق
بالمطالبه كثير
لليمين بالخروج الى الشارع هل تلمستم بدا
خروج اي حد او لا
يعني صحيح يوجد هنا عشرات يعني اعداد
قليله حتى الان من اليمينيين يتظاهرون مع
هذه التعديلات القضائيه ولكن ايضا لمسناها
ليله امس حيث يعني شاهدنا ايضا عشرات من
المتظاهرين يؤيدون التعديلات القضائيه
ويعني يوجد هناك كان اشتباكات بين اليمين
واليسار حتى في الشارع وهذا ما لمسناه
وكان هناك تدخل من قبل الجيش الاسرائيلي
لمحاوله فعليا فض او وقف هذا الاشتباكات
بين الطرفين في طبيعه الامر شاهدنا او
سمعنا ان يعني في الاعلام الاسرائيلي
الخطاب يتحدث عن حرب اهليه او حتى عن
انقلاب عسكري ولكن الان بدنا نراه ونشهده
في الارض الواقع وهذا ما يعني يحذر منه
عدد كبير من الرؤساء في اسرائيل